[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kirk bowles is on vacation but that
doesn't stop him from working
he is a sports columnist for the austin
american statesman
co-host of on second thought his podcast
he tweeted out the following today
prominent big 12 source tells the
american statesman that the texas
oklahoma move to the sec
is almost done quote they've been
working on this for a minimum of six
months
and the texas a m leadership was left
out of the discussions and wasn't told
about it
move could become official in a week
kirk kind enough to join us on vacation
from minnesota
kirk when did you start to get the
feeling that this was real
well actually dan i go back to a week
ago last friday i had a tip from
an sec source that this would maybe in
the works
and i was trying to nail it down before
vacation i wasn't able to do that
in part then because uh when i talked to
the oklahoma a.d joe castiglione
he kind of poo-pooed the whole thing to
me and said oh you know there's so many
rumors out in the summer
go on your vacation no problem and uh
the texas president i talked to him too
on last friday and
he kind of said there are so many rumors
out there i can't
i can't talk about all of them so kind
of went on the back burner but it
sure heated up that's for sure where are
we today
where are we today we are on a runaway
train then
uh you know sarkeesian's uh motto
is uh all gas no brakes and i'm not sure
there are any brakes on
on this story either and it's just kind
of kind of writing an
angry rhinoceros or something a lot of
pissed off people
i'll say that then well you do mention
in the uh
in the tweet that texas a m wasn't even
consulted on this
how is that possible that well okay
should they
did they have to consult a m on texas
and oklahoma leaving
well i'll put it this way you know uh
every league
says okay 14 team members in the sec and
they're all equal partners
the problem with that is some are more
equal than others than you know did
and i don't think uh a m's equalness
kind of equates to some of the other
ones and quite frankly a m
has been very out front they want to
kill this whole thing they want to watch
it
you know they're in the sec for a reason
they wanted to get out from under texas
shadow so
you know this is their worst nightmare
right now i think and so
i think they're moving heaven and earth
to try to
stop this at the last minute but i just
don't like their chances
okay explain the game plan i had
mentioned if i'm oklahoma
i could stay oklahoma in the big 12 and
i'm guaranteed a playoff spot every
single year
yes you know texas you're being
dominated in the big 12
you know how do you like your chances in
the sec so i'm just that's
from you know a million miles away
applying logic to this
uh take that apart why is oklahoma
joining the sec
hey don't let it logic get in the way of
money okay okay
we know we know what the driving force
behind college athletics is
all you got to do is look at the last
you know few changes with the transfer
portal and
name image and likeness and immediate
eligibility
and so you know i'm not going to say
this is an out and out money grab
but they would get so much more money
they would get so much more prestige it
is the premier conference we all know
that
uh there's no denying that and as much
as anything
dan i think it's a lot has to do with
football scheduling
and even though texas has i mean they've
got series home and home with alabama
georgia
florida between now and uh 2031.
but the problem is the big 12 you don't
have the tv draw or the ticket draw
that you do in the sec you know they can
look at a
m and a m every other year has a alabama
lsu coming in auburn and here comes a
florida georgia
texas is trying to sell tickets to no
disrespect
you know kansas kansas state iowa state
and those teams just don't move the
needle like sec teams so
i think that's as big a function of this
and you know they're remodeling the
south end zone at
war memorial stadium that'll be ready
for the louisiana game
on september 4th and they're building a
brand new basketball center moody center
that will be
ready in like a year and a half what
happens to the big 12
bye bye i mean i just i don't see how
they compete
i mean you know they made 34 and a half
million in a covered year that was their
share of tv revenue you know while sec
is looking at 45 million
i've heard it might grow to 60 million a
year per school
if texas and oklahoma joined but
you know if i were them i'd throw out
the life raft and
knock on the pac-12 door and see if the
big ten's interested
but are the acc but you know so many of
them were going to be left behind when
we went through this last wave of
expansion in texas
and oklahoma and others flirted with the
pac-12 right to the
11th hour so but i think they're looking
for any life raft
in the ocean they can find and i would
be putting out feeders to houston and
smu
cincinnati ucf maybe byu and boise state
even so
it kind of becomes every man for himself
i just get down to it
i just wonder if we're headed towards
maybe four
divisions 10 teams 12 teams
and you just make it like the nfl model
and
now there's you're going to have great
matchups every week week in and week out
you can have
12 14 16 playoff teams like the nfl does
do you think we're headed in that
direction at some point kirk well it
wouldn't surprise me
i was pretty much blindsided when you
know they started talking about going to
12 team playoff you know
we've all been trying to go to six and
in at least eight and then all of a
sudden boom
let's go to 12. you know and then when
does 12 become 24.
so you know it's kind of the uh
professionalization
of college athletics if you will when
you see a bryce young may be making a
million dollars off
nioh endorsements i mean this is not
your granddad's
you know college football game anymore
and it just gets
more and more big time and the dollars
just get bigger and bigger
and everybody wants their share nobody
wants to be left behind so
that would not surprise me at all then
you guys wanted nick saban at texas a
few years back
well you get him but he's just going to
be the visiting coach there
they take they'll take nick saban part
two in sarkeesian and uh
i like to have nick here every other
year that would be fun too
uh enjoy your vacation great job as
always thanks for joining us kirk
anytime dan take care that's kirk bowles
he is the columnist for the american
austin american statesman